[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute ist uns nach kleinen Teigtaschen,
also Poğaça auf Türkisch.
Und wir machen die jetzt heute vegetarisch
und wie so eine kleine Rolle.
Ich hole mir gleich auch Samira und Ela zum Helfen.
Ich werde jetzt aber zuerst mal einen Hefeteig zubereiten
mit etwas Joghurt.
Das macht den Hefeteig einfach super weich und zart
und auch saftig.
Bringt auch so eine leichte Säure mit rein.
Und die Zutaten
habe ich eigentlich immer zu Hause.
Ich denke, ihr auch.
Und wir starten jetzt auch direkt.
Also dafür nehme ich einen halben Würfel Hefe,
einen Teelöffel Zucker,
100 Gramm lauwarmes Wasser.
Hier habe ich 500 Gramm Mehl.
Da könnt ihr Weizen- oder Dinkelmehl nehmen.
Ein Eiweiß,
200 Gramm Naturjoghurt. Das ist der dreieinhalbprozentige.
Eineinhalb Teelöffel Salz und 100 Gramm weiche Butter.
Also zuerst einmal
nehme ich jetzt die Hefe
und löse sie hier im warmen Wasser auf.
Aber ich glaube, ich mache das hier gleich
in der großen Rührschüssel.
Denn sonst verschütte ich.
Also warmes Wasser rein.
Hefe reinbröseln.
[Musik]
Den Zucker auch mit reingeben und kurz verrühren.
Gerne auch schon ein bisschen Mehl.
Den Vorteig lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz aufgehen.
Einfach abdecken und so zehn Minuten,
etwa zehn bis zwanzig Minuten stehen lassen,
bis er sich vergrößert hat.
Ich mache das jetzt hier direkt mit Hitze.
Da geht es nämlich schneller.
Am besten so bei 28°C.
Da vermehrt sich die Hefe nämlich optimal.
Dann geht es jetzt weiter hier mit dem Hefeteig.
Beim Hefeteig immer darauf achten,
dass Salz und Fett zum Schluss drankommt.
Also jetzt auch schön zuerst das Mehl dazu geben.
Dann das Eiweiß.
Denn Salz und Fett hindern einfach die Hefe am Aufgehen.
Daher immer zum Schluss dazu geben.
Jetzt den Joghurt noch dazu geben.
Den gebe ich jetzt auch nicht direkt auf die Hefe,
sondern eher in die Mehlmischung,
damit die Hefe einfach zum Schluss erst
mit dem Fett in Kontakt kommt.
Ich rühre jetzt auch schon mal,
gebe dann das Salz dazu
und dann die Butter.
Und jetzt lasse ich den Hefeteig für etwa zehn Minuten kneten,
damit er richtig schön geschmeidig wird.
Mit der Hand könnt ihr ihn auch gerne kneten.
Hat auch immer was Meditatives und Beruhigendes.
Aber ich mache es jetzt so.
Denn dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit aufräumen.
[Musik]
So sieht der Hefeteig jetzt wunderbar aus.
Und er klebt auch nicht, wie ihr sehen könnt.
Der ist einfach richtig wunderschön weich geworden.
Ein kleines bisschen zu weich ist er jetzt doch geworden.
Also noch ganz wenig Mehl reinkneten.
[Musik]
Jetzt hat er eine schöne Konsistenz.
Jetzt forme ich den einfach zu einer schönen Kugel
[Musik]
und lasse ihn dann abgedeckt für 30 bis 60 Minuten aufgehen,
bis er sich richtig schön verdoppelt hat.
[Musik]
Der Hefeteig ist jetzt perfekt aufgegangen.
Jetzt geht es an die Füllung.
Ich mache hier jetzt eine Füllung aus Hirtenkäse,
Frischkäse,
etwas Porree,
Petersilie und Pfeffer.
Und ich muss jetzt zuerst mal den Porree klein schneiden.
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier die dunklen Blätter erst mal weg.
Und den wasche ich immer ganz gerne nach dem Schneiden.
Das geht echt einfacher.
So die dunkelgrünen wegnehmen.
Aber die könnt ihr wunderbar
für eine Gemüsebrühe zum Beispiel verwenden.
Und jetzt den Rest einfach fein schneiden.
[Musik]
Ich finde Porree so schön, weil man da so
so voll den natürlichen Farbverlauf drin hat.
Ist schon schön.
Ombré!
Ombré-Effekt!
Ich habe jetzt hier eine Salatschleuder
und auch schon Wasser drin.
Und jetzt kann ich es hier nämlich reingeben
und schön durchschleudern.
Und so entfernt ihr den kompletten Sand einfach.
[Musik]
Weil Lauch, Porree ist schon immer sehr, sehr sandig.
Hm.
[Musik]
Nur ganz vorsichtig ziehen,
damit kein Brunnen entsteht.
Wenn ich jetzt einmal feste ziehe, dann habe ich hier
einen Springbrunnen.
Jetzt kurz abgießen
und dann noch mal richtig trocken schleudern.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich jetzt hier ein Käserädchen
und zerbrösel es so mit der Hand.
[Musik]
Da kommt jetzt der Porree dazu.
Die Füllung hat meine Mama immer gemacht,
wenn sie Rosen-Börek gemacht hat,
also mit so dünnen Yufka-Blättern.
Dann ein bisschen Petersilie dazu.
Die habe ich jetzt aus dem Gefrierfach.
Da habe ich nämlich immer gehackte Petersilie auf Vorrat,
wenn ich im Sommer einfach ganz viel habe,
und dann friere ich die immer ein, bevor sie schlecht wird.
Dann noch etwas Pfeffer dazu geben.
Pfeffer immer schön frisch gemahlen.
Und Frischkäse.
[Musik]
Und jetzt einfach kurz alles vermischen.
Jetzt teile ich den Teig in 16 Portionen ein.
Entweder macht ihr das so dann direkt,
erst vierteln, dann noch mal vierteln jedes Viertel,
oder
mit einem Teigportionierer,
Torteneinteiler.
Schön!
[Musik]
Dann zu kleinen Kugeln formen.
Hier, komm, du kriegst noch eine Schürze.
>> ELA: Ich mache das schon mal.
>> SALLY: Hast du Hände gewaschen?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Ganz gründlich?
>> ELA: Ja. Du hast das...
>> SALLY: Warte. Ich mache kurz die Bällchen.
>> ELA: Du hast das doch gerade eben gesehen. Oder nicht?
>> SALLY: Nein. Ich habe es nur gehört.
Samira, komm.
Warte. Ich mache kurz die Kugeln fertig.
>> ELA: Ich mache es auch.
>> SALLY: So?
>> ELA: Ich kann es auch.
>> SALLY: Okay. Zeig.
Wow!
>> ELA: Erst mal so.
>> SALLY: Du kannst das echt schon besser
als mancher Erwachsene.
>> ELA: Braucht man dafür so was?
>> SALLY: Gleich.
Aber erst brauchen wir eine Kugel.
>> ELA: Erst mal so.
>> SALLY: Machen wir hier ein bisschen Platz.
Dann kann Abla auch dazu.
>> ELA: Guck. Den Teig macht man so
und verschmiert es nicht überall.
Sondern man nimmt es überall, wo es verteilt ist.
>> SALLY: Super!
Hadi güzelim.
>> ELA: Guck mal, bei mir spielt es ja verrückt!
>> SALLY: Na ja.
Guck. Bei dir brauchen wir ein bisschen, bisschen Mehl.
Und dann so von außen nach innen.
Und eine schöne Kugel.
Genau. So, wie es Abla gemacht hat.
>> ELA: Und...
>> SALLY: Also wie beim Weinblätterwickeln
nehmt ihr jetzt eine Teigkugel.
Guckt ihr mir zu?
>> SAMIRA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Weil wir machen jetzt alle gleich. Okay?
Und dann haben wir gleich Poğaça.
Tamam, Ela?
Ela, hörst du mir zu?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Sicher?
Ich kann nämlich auf dich gucken.
>> SALLY: Du sollst hierhin gucken.
>> ELA: Da gucke ich auch gerade.
>> SALLY: Sie will mir gerade zeigen,
dass sie aus dem Augenwinkel das sieht.
Siehst du, was ich mache?
>> ELA: N- Ja!
>> SAMIRA: Was macht sie gerade?
>> SALLY: Und jetzt kommt einfach
mit dem Eisportionierer hier die Füllung rein.
Und wirklich wie beim Weintraubenwickeln
hier ein bisschen verteilen
und dann
hier oben einschlagen. Gell, Ela?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Und dann den Rand einschlagen.
>> SAMIRA: Und dann einwickeln.
>> SALLY: Und einwickeln.
>> ELA: Und dann noch...
>> SAMIRA: Das ist ja sozusagen Sarma.
Nur mit...
>> SALLY: Sarma nur mit Teig.
>> SAMIRA: Und mit anderer Füllung.
>> SALLY: So.
Und dann sieht das aus wie so eine Frühlingsrolle.
>> ELA: Mama, warte!
Da muss man doch immer so
Mehl außenrum machen oben!
>> SALLY: Au ja!
Okay.
Also komm, jetzt machen wir das alle zusammen.
>> ELA: Erst so.
>> SALLY: Abla kim, Ela?
>> SAMIRA: So, Mama?
>> SALLY: Super!
Einfach ein schönes Rechteck.
>> ELA: Ich brauche kurz!
>> SALLY: Den Ausrollstab?
>> ELA: Ja.
>> SALLY: Nach oben rollen.
Jetzt den Rand einschlagen.
>> ELA: Der Rand ist nicht so wie die Blätter.
Das ist Murat!
>> SALLY: Warum?
>> ELA: Weil er echt dick ist.
>> SAMIRA: Mama.
>> ELA: Dick wie ein Rollbrötchen!
>> SALLY: Och, Ela!
>> ELA: Dick wie ein Rollenbrötchen!
>> SALLY: Ja.
Aber guck mal, jetzt gar nicht so viel Mehl nehmen. Okay?
Das ist jetzt zu viel Mehl.
[Musik]
Jetzt habe ich hier ein Eigelb.
Das verrühre ich jetzt mit zwei Esslöffeln Sahne.
Ihr könnt aber auch Milch nehmen zum Beispiel.
Und dann werden die Teilchen bestrichen.
[Musik]
Jetzt hier noch schön Sesam und Schwarzkümmel drauf.
Und dann kommen sie schon in den Backofen.
Ich stelle sie jetzt in den kalten Backofen
und heize dann den Ofen erst auf.
Und dann kann nämlich die Aufgehzeit
direkt als Aufheizzeit genutzt werden.
Ansonsten könnt ihr sie jetzt noch mal abdecken
und dann im heißen Ofen backen.
Aber ich finde es eigentlich immer ganz gut.
Kalter Ofen,
hat das Gebäck noch Zeit zum Aufgehen.
[Musik]
>> MURAT: Ist auch schön.
Ich bin Murat.
Und das ist die schönste Tischdecke der Welt.
Okay.
Ja.
>> SALLY: Was hast du gegen Blumenshirts?
>> MURAT: Weiß nicht.
Ich finde...
Ich denke immer, wenn ich an das Ding...
Wenn ich dein T-Shirt sehe, denke ich immer:
Krass, was die schon auf Tischdecken drucken können!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Okay.
Dann gehen wir weiter.
Und zwar geht es eigentlich gar nicht um die Tischdecken.
Und zwar es geht um das hier.
Das nennt sich
Poğaça, nehme ich an, oder?
>> SALLY: Ich denke mir gerade so:
Muss ich mir das gefallen lassen?
>> MURAT: Nein.
Du kannst mich auch rauswerfen.
Aber das Haus gehört mir. Dann hast du ein Problem.
[Musik]
Ja.
>> SALLY: Döt!
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> MURAT: Also Poğaça oder Börek?
Ich weiß den Unterschied da nicht.
>> SALLY: Das heißt nicht Pogaça.
>> MURAT: Wie heißt es?
>> SALLY: Poğaça.
>> MURAT: Poğaça.
>> SALLY: Mit yumuşak ge.
>> MURAT: Ja. Yumuşak ge mit Poğaça.
>> SALLY: Ja, Börek ist immer
Börek eher, Yufka und so.
Und das ist Poğaça, klein, handlich,
aus der Hand essen.
>> MURAT: Ich bin ein Poğaça!
So.
Klein, handlich.
Ich bin ein Poğaça!
>> SALLY: Du bist ein Pogaça
und das ist ein Poğaça.
>> MURAT: Okay.
>> SALLY: Also probier mal.
Das ist keiner Hackfleisch drin, nehme ich an. Oder?
>> SALLY: Nein.
>> MURAT: Hey, ich liebe die Dinger mit Hackfleisch!
Die sind so genial! Ich schwöre.
Da könnte ich bestimmt 20 Stück davon essen.
Mmh!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Man sieht es.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Mmh!
[Musik]
Hammer!
Ganz ehrlich,
die müsst ihr warm essen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Hm.
Wirklich!
So warm essen.
Nach einem Tag sind sie auch noch cool.
Nach dem dritten Tag
auch noch. Nach dem vierten...
>> SALLY: Nach einem Tag sind die schon noch richtig gut.
Also ich finde sie halt ganz heiß aus dem Ofen, so wie jetzt,
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: am besten.
Am nächsten Tag sind sie auch noch gut.
Aber da erwärme ich sie lieber auf dem Toaster
oder im Backofen.
>> MURAT: Oder
luftdicht verschließen.
>> SALLY: Ja, auf jeden Fall.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Aber die sind doch voll lecker!
>> SALLY: Muss nicht immer Fleisch sein, Schatz!
>> MURAT: Ja. Aber Fleisch wäre auch cool gewesen.
Die schmecken so lecker!
>> SALLY: Mir fehlt jetzt nur ein bisschen Chili.
>> MURAT: Du hattest schon mal ein Rezept gemacht,
wo Hackfleischfüllung war. Kann das sein?
>> SALLY: Ja, ich weiß. Ja.
>> MURAT: Oh, das ist so lecker! Ich träume nur noch davon.
>> SALLY: Mir fehlt jetzt noch ein bisschen Chili.
Ich würde jetzt noch Chili reinmachen.
Aber ich habe es nicht wegen den Kindern,
dass die gleich mitessen können.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und Ela und Samira, die haben mitgemacht.
>> SALLY: Und zwar soll ich dir von Ela ausrichten...
Warte kurz.
Der müsste es sein.
Den hat Ela gemacht.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann hat sie gesagt: "Das ist der Papa."
Dann habe ich gesagt: "Warum denn, mein Schatz?"
Und dann hat sie gesagt: "Der ist klein und dick."
>> MURAT: Oh!
>> SALLY: Und dann hat sie den nächsten gemacht
und hat gesagt: "Und das ist der Güni."
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: "Der ist auch dick."
>> MURAT: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> MURAT: Hausarrest.
>> SALLY: Wir haben uns vorhin totgelacht!
>> MURAT: Bis sie 14 ist, Hausarrest.
>> SALLY: Wir haben uns einfach totgelacht!
Das war die ganze Zeit: "Oh, das ist der Papa."
"Mh, das ist der Güni."
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Ich liebe das so arg! Ehrlich!
Ganz toll!
>> SALLY: Ich auch. Und ich...
Das ist so was Gefährliches,
weil man isst es dann so aus der Hand
und isst und isst und isst. Und
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SALLY: deswegen. Ja.
Na ja.
Ich mache jetzt noch einen Tee dazu, weil Tee passt perfekt.
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Und dann setzen wir uns auf die Terrasse,
essen Poğaça mit den Kindern.
>> MURAT: Ja.
Und ich glaube, das liebt jeder.
Es wird keinen Menschen geben, der das nicht mag.
>> SALLY: Ich glaube es auch.
>> MURAT: Ich kann mir es nicht vorstellen.
>> SALLY: Und früher,
als ich noch im Kindergarten war oder in der Schule,
hat meine Mama immer so Sachen gebacken,
Poğaça oder Börek.
Und da haben sich immer alle gefreut,
wenn meine Mama mit zum Ausflug kam.
Denn türkische Mamas bringen immer was mit zum Ausflug.
>> MURAT: Man merkt auch...
>> SALLY: War es bei euch auch so?
>> MURAT: Hm.
>> SALLY: Türkische Mamas bringen immer was mit,
auch beim Fußballverein.
Alle,
alle anderen lieben türkische Mamas.
>> SALLY & MURAT: Ja.
>> MURAT: Man merkt auch gar nicht,
wie schnell man es isst, gell?
>> SALLY: Ich merke es.
>> MURAT: Merkt man gar nicht.
>> SALLY: Voll langsam.
Also
>> MURAT: Die haut man einfach rein.
>> SALLY: viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Und
bis zum nächsten Mal!
>> MURAT: Ja.
>> SALLY: Tschüss!
>> MURAT: Ich will noch einen türkischen Satz sagen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> MURAT: Ramazan Bayramınız mübarek olsun.
Wenn...
Okay?
War falsch?
Ich gehe.
Tschüss! Macht es gut!
[Musik]